- I don't value people's judgment.
I think people struggle with judgment.
If you're judging me, you're weak.
Not me.
You've got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] Thank you very much.
I'm gonna walk up with this
cause it's really weird
to stand right at the back of
the room to ask a question.
My question is around the,
you spoke about the wanting admiration,
which I think is a really
courageous thing to admit to.
But in your book, Crushing It,
you also talk about altruism
and how important that is.
Where do you see the line between the two,
because my career is all
about helping charities
and nonprofits, and I'm
terrified at the idea
of losing myself in the spotlight.
So where do you see the
line between the two?
- You know, I think the
thing that I talked about
very quickly up there
about I want health for you
and then I want self-awareness,
I think the line is everybody
here has got a different line.
I don't think anybody here should live
on anybody else's line.
I think the key is to try
to figure yourself out.
I didn't realize the reason
that I was a class clown
was because I wanted attention
because I was getting it at home.
I think the line goes in a lot of places.
I think that truth matters the most.
There's a lot of people
that play in nonprofit.
When I sit on nonprofit boards,
and I realize that people join that board
to get access to me for business purposes,
that was a real eye-opener to me.
And so, I think everybody
has their own line.
But I think it's important to expose
what you're selfish about,
because so many people
try to position themselves
as selfless at all causes,
and that's just not human.
I think admiration doesn't
feel very courageous to me,
because the way I process it is,
I'm desperate to bring you more value
than you bring to me
so that I have leverage
of your admiration, which, by virtue,
feels like you're just
wanting to be a good person
for the sake of something that's in you.
So, I just think that
you have to draw the line
where you draw the line.
And, listen, if you're naturally
private, that's super fine.
My question is why, though.
I think one of the biggest reasons people
are naturally private is
cause they're hiding things.
They want two things.
They want stuff, but they also want
to keep certain things secrets.
And so, I just think you
have to be thoughtful.
If you're not honest with yourself,
you're fundamentally finished.
And I think that's what I'm pushing on.
- [Woman] Awesome, thank you so much.
- You got it.
(audience claps)
- [Man] I have two,
originally I had one question,
gonna ask two cause the first
one's gonna be pretty quick.
Trying to be brave there.
(laughs)
The first one is if you were to target
the C-level executives within
a channel, what would you use?
- LinkedIn.
LinkedIn, if you're in B2B,
or you're trying to
get to business people,
I am blown away.
I actually tweeted this the other day.
I'm just stunned how much
of a content platform LinkedIn has become.
Because, for a lot of us here,
LinkedIn was a utility for recruiting
and just reaching out to people.
Using LinkedIn is not spamming
people on LinkedIn Messaging.
Using LinkedIn is using LinkedIn the way
you use Facebook or Twitter,
putting out meaningful content.
It finds itself to the
right people in that world.
- [Man] Second question is,
in the intro part of a journey,
how important do you think your purpose,
or whatever you're gonna call it,
is it to stay the course?
- I think being happy,
and that's what I think
all these words, passion,
being happy is imperative
because it takes so many hours.
It takes so many hours
to beat the other people
to get yours, kind of thing,
or just to take advantage
of the abundance.
I just think an enormous amount of people
do it for the money,
which has nothing to do with happiness.
And so, I think purpose, passion, process.
I get such a high out of the tough part.
I like the bad stuff.
I like the setbacks.
I'm actually unbelievably
addicted to the negativities
of running a business, the hard parts.
- [Man] Can that give you
part of your goals as well?
Cause when you like the process,
sometimes you just get it.
- When you love the process,
you've achieved your goal.
You have to understand, the money, for me,
is the collateral to loving the process.
Even the way you asked that question,
you're looking for more
money than I'm looking for.
And, by the way, that
doesn't mean I'm right.
Just even the way you asked the question,
I've already won by putting
myself in the process.
All the other part is secondary, got it?
So you're not gonna to
be in it for the process.
I mean that, which is
okay, it really is okay.
The key is trying to figure out
why you want the other stuff.
It's okay to want money, why?
A lot of people love the idea of money
so they don't have to work.
That usually doesn't work out.
- [Man] Alright, next question.
Let's keep the questions
to only one please.
- [Man] Hi, Gary, I'm Joel.
I'm 31 years old this year.
I just want to ask,
I know you know this already,
but national service is
like a compulsory thing
for all males in this
country, so, military service.
So I'm working this out,
sometime mid next year.
Entering occupations, and
again, bigger picture like,
how do you work around,
putting your whole life on hold
for pretty much a few years?
- Because you have no choice.
- [Man] Yeah, and then
the world's going so fast
when I finish in three years--
- The world will be there for you
when you're done doing
your military service.
Just because you don't want to do it,
or because you're excited to do this stuff
that you want to be doing
but you're mandatory,
you were born in Singapore, bro.
You're going to the fucking military.
(audience laughs)
That's just the way it is and that's that.
And so, there's pros
and cons to everything.
You could have been born
in an indigenous country.
There's a lot worse places
to win the lottery than Singapore.
You, like Israel and
other places in the world,
you're going to have to pay your services.
But this whole thought
that I'm going to miss out
on my time is ludicrous.
If you're good enough,
if you're good enough,
the years that you were in the military
aren't going to be the reasons you lost.
Don't use it as an excuse, bro.
- [Joel] Alright, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Man] Hey, Gary, it's
me again, from India.
I've been chasing you since 2008.
- Yes.
- [Man] I was a software engineer.
This good?
- No, just get closer to the mic.
- [Man] Can I come?
- I'm fine with it, but if
they want to not let you,
I'm in their house so I
have to be respectful.
- [Man] Okay, I understand.
So, I was a software engineer.
- I remember.
- [Man] I was still in like 2017.
- [Man] Then I become an executive,
and I do the firewall for an agency.
It's a business--
- Yup.
- I have my own business,
it's called Market.
It's on Booking.com.
So, I want 27 words, and I want 27 words
for the seven wonders
of the world altogether.
We are gonna advertise with a mixed market
and many companies in India to go there,
promotions and everything.
And here also, I was telling you,
and you know those writings I use
in your Facebook to promote their event.
I guess they have less
audiences there, I don't know.
But I just want to tell you.
- Thank you.
- [Man] And I come here, last
night you were in Malaysia,
so I was tracking you on Twitter as well,
so I was tracking you and
your photographer was shooting
so I took his picture as well.
And in here also, I just want you to know
that I think you are ingenious.
- Thank you very much.
- [Man] That is just a courtesy.
- I respect that.
- [Man] I don't require money.
I've been watching this evening.
I don't spend hundreds of dollars,
and I want to know how to do things.
I'm just 25 years old,
and I think I have just five more years
to place every bet I have on this planet
to make it successful
for everyone around me.
- Good for you, man.
- [Man] Yeah.
So do I get an internship?
(laughs)
- That was the question?
- [Man] Yeah.
- So, internship in New York?
- The biggest problem is,
I don't know if you've
been reading the news but--
- [Man] I get the visa, I'll
get everything you know.
- You get the visa,
I'm absolutely open to it.
- [Man] I get the visa, I get the visa,
I work no cost for you.
- Ready? Yes.
- [Man] Yeah, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Man] Alright, great job.
Next question.
- [Man] Do I ask anyone?
- Me, Gary@vaynermedia.
- [Man] Gary@vaynermedia.com?
- Yup.
- [Man] Do I still need to send you my CV?
What else should I send you?
- Your email and say,
"I got the internship."
- [Man] I got, wow, thank you.
I just wanted to hear this, thank you.
- You got it.
- [Man] Great job.
Next question.
Remember one question and keep it short.
- No statements and requests?
Go ahead.
- [Man] I come from Perth.
Really good to see you again.
Okay, the one, but my question is--
- Yeah I was looking at him
I was like might be soon.
- [Man] But yeah, my question
is more a bit practical.
In the next 12 to 24 months,
we're looking to go in early into Voice,
so the Spice.
What do we do to go all
in, preparing for the fact
that some of the platforms, platform in.
- Yeah, I would download all of the apps,
and I would get involved
in all of the conversations
because there's not enough to do just yet.
- [Man] Yeah, okay.
- It's just like iPhone apps.
You know what else you could do?
Go read about the first
two years of iPhone apps.
- [Man] Okay.
- Be very educated on
2007 and eight iPhone apps
because what happened there
is gonna happen on Voice.
Look for patterns.
- [Man] Good, thanks.
- [Justin] What's up, Gary?
- How are you?
- [Justin] I'm good.
My name's Justin, from Perth as well,
with Perth Crew.
It's so hard to ask you a question.
I mean you give so much value,
and some of the questions
that are asked like,
guys, seriously, wake the fuck up.
But, I wanted to ask a
real practical question,
a little bit operational, right.
So, I run a service business out of Perth.
How do you, you talk
about giving value, right?
- Yes.
- [Justin] Value, value, value.
Something that we struggle, I guess,
as growing a service business,
is this client management.
- Yes.
- [Justin] And you shared,
I think, a couple nuggets
here and there across, very rarely,
around even being anxious
around some client challenges,
like coming out on this event, and like,
dealing with the challenges.
My question is how do
you empower your team
to give value verses
running money at a loss,
and obviously in the large scale business,
how do you empower client management teams
to make decisions of value verses just
burning budget dollars?
- By continuing, this is a
very good question, by the way.
A lot of communication with them.
I think the biggest issue that
client service people make
is they make decisions
they think the client needs
without listening very
carefully to the client.
Every client is in control
of the subjective nature
of what the value is that they bring.
Some like schmooze, some
like black and white.
I think what you're
looking for is empathy.
The best client service
people have deep empathy,
which gives them the ability to know
which way to turn.
The way I empower them is
by having the conversation
around this with them, and then watching
what they do with it, not by caging them
into something.
It's a very human thing.
Like, as good as I feel about it,
it could change tomorrow
because a new client's
been put on that business.
The nature of client service business
is not having control, which is why
I've been very good at it,
because I'm very comfortable
in not having control.
You're in control of firing
your client service people.
That's what you have.
Not super complicated.
You just need to know
what you signed up for.
Yeah.
- [Justin] Thanks, Gary, cheers, bro.
- [Man] So, last year,
I'm actually from Myanmar.
So, I follow you since last year, August,
until this January.
I follow you for six months.
Now, I don't really
anymore cause I started
to win actually.
My question here is you can see Myanmar.
It's a very diplomatic country.
So, I actually started
my own marketing agency.
If you're not bargaining pressure,
I think you not go to,
like, let's say America,
or even in Singapore, if
you're bordering a country,
what will you do to sell the company
because you have chains everywhere?
So, what would you do?
- One more time, I wanna make sure
I understand the question.
- [Man] So, I'm actually
a digital marketing
agency like you.
- I understand.
- [Man] Yeah, so if you're not,
if you don't born in America,
or if you're not in Singapore,
if you're in a developing country,
how would you start up a company?
- The same way I would do it in America.
I would get a client, the first client,
take the money, and start
building from scratch.
Are you making the
assumption, or positioning
that there's more dollars in the system
in bigger countries?
- [Man] Actually, nobody,
no one technically
understands what digital marketing is.
- Nobody understands it in America either.
- [Man] Okay, sounds good.
- I'm being serious.
I actually think it's more interesting
in doing business in developing markets
because to your point, nobody understands.
What you're alluding to is that means
a lot of people are gonna say no to you.
People say no everywhere.
- [Man] Yes.
- You know what's good about
being in a developing country,
where a lot of customers are saying no?
You're not competing with a lot of people.
It's easier to build a
digital marketing agency,
especially if you're
somebody who's been watching
me carefully for six
months, in a third world
or developing country, that it is
in Singapore or America.
Easier.
So, go show me.
- [Man] Okay, thank you, Gary.
- [Man] Hi, Gary, my name is Parshed.
So, I have one question.
Because I've seen a
your company force even,
how do you maximize your
time, efficiency, everything?
- By hiring two full time assistants
who try to make sure I don't do anything
that's logistics oriented, or doesn't
take up my time.
By number two, not judging myself
if I had a bad day that wasn't as valuable
as it could've been,
and then also on Fridays
and Sundays, reviewing
the two weeks ahead,
every single minute I'm spending
to make it a little bit better
if I have the chance to cancel something,
and bring something in.
- [Man] How do you actually
handle your bad days?
- I mean, I don't have a lot of bad days,
mainly because I made my bed.
I think if you're a CEO, or a founder,
or an entrepreneur, I
don't think it's acceptable
to kind of almost acknowledge bad days,
not that you should suppress feelings.
My bad days are handled with perspective.
If my family is healthy,
losing a big client, or
having an issue in my business
is not a bad day.
It's about perspective.
The CEO of Pepsi, Indra
canceled my meeting
with her the other day,
and I probably won't
see her now for six months.
It was a meeting I was looking forward to
for three or four months, very important.
I thought I could really
set up VaynerMedia for 2019.
It got canceled.
I doubt that I will see
her the rest of the year.
I didn't consider that a bad day.
I considered that a
fuck, part of the game.
Like, I hate it.
I wish it happened, but
I think too many people
consider things a bad day
cause a client service person
fucked up.
You have to put things in perspective.
- [Man] Okay, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Shannon] Hi, Gary, my name is Shannon.
- Hey, Shannon.
- [Shannon] I'm into restoring life.
- Good.
- [Shannon] So, with your latest book
being titled Crushing
It, you share about times
when you were really
crushed, like what happened,
and how did you overcome it?
- I don't think I've really had that time
happen yet.
I anticipate it could happen,
but it's not different than I
told the gentleman just now.
I reserve being crushed
for when my parents die,
or something awful happens to my children.
I don't, I'm not a businessman
that over extends myself
so that I can go out of business,
and I'm not somebody that really cares
about anybody's judgment on me.
The answer is I don't have an
answer to your question yet.
Hopefully, when that day comes,
I'll be able to deploy perspective
and be grateful for the
good things I did have.
I don't operate that way.
- [Shannon] So, how do
you psych yourself up
to be like so positive every single day,
and when negative things come,
you're just like oh, you know, heck it?
- I don't value other people's opinion.
I really mean this, guys.
I don't value your opinion.
Like, I just, I don't value people's,
you know, actually, I might
have to start changing that.
I never thought of this, cause I do
value the feedback tremendously.
I don't value people's judgment.
I think people struggle with judgment.
If you're judging me, you're weak, not me.
So, I don't struggle with judgment.
I just don't understand what people think
when something bad happens.
I don't, I think people put themselves
into traps, emotional and financially.
Emotionally, they allow judgment
to dictate their behavior.
Then, financially, you
over extend yourself,
and then, when you lose an
account, you're in trouble.
I mean, I could lose all
of VaynerMedia's business.
I'm gonna make almost as
much money on this trip
for three days than I'll
make at VaynerMedia.
I'm not kidding cause I'm
investing it all back.
I don't live my life in a way
that I'm trapped financially.
I also can live my life
without fancy things.
I think people are fucking fancy.
You know why people are fancy?
They want to have a
facade to other people.
If tomorrow, I lived in
an apartment in Newark,
I'd be super fucking fine with it.
Maybe it would be a struggle for me
because my wife would struggle with it,
my kids would struggle with it,
but for me, for me, I'm
fucking cool with it
because guess what, what, what.
- [Shannon] Okay, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Man] Hi, Gary, my name is Razi.
I'm a digital marketing
agency for the past six years.
Earlier you mentioned about
the little voice of doubt
that comes in our head,
and how that was not
as pleased by someone else.
So, my question to you is how does one
overcome the little voice of doubt
that always crops up
whenever something big,
like when you ask someone out,
or go pitch to a big client?
How does one overcome that little voice?
- By recognizing,
regardless of that voice,
the outcome of what they do isn't gonna
be predicated by the fear
and the doubt going into it.
Meaning, all the fear
you had when you first
jumped into a pool swimming, wasn't gonna
dictate how good at
swimming you were gonna be.
I mean, it has no impact.
- [Man] Got it.
- Your doubt isn't gonna win or lose,
you know how people are like I'm gonna
psych myself up for this pitch,
and they get really pumped for the pitch,
and then they lose the business.
Well, it didn't work.
- [Man] Got it.
- In the same way that
you could doubt something
and then it went well, and
you're like oh, that went.
That is a very important conversation,
but what you need to
understand is it has no value.
It's not right.
- [Man] So, just ignore
it is what you're saying.
- Once you start believing it's not right,
and then you do 20 things,
and sometimes the doubt
was right, and sometimes
the doubt was wrong,
you start realizing it doesn't matter.
What I struggle with is how people
don't understand after
they've lived some life,
like what the results were of their life.
You've had this doubt.
Sometimes it worked out,
sometimes it didn't.
It sounds like your doubt isn't accurate.
- [Man] Got it, thanks, Gary.
- You're welcome.
Do you know that I go
into every business thing
thinking I'm gonna win it?
Guess what, it's wrong.
Because I haven't won every
single thing I've done,
but that's my default.
But, I don't let it affect me.
Do you understand?
I'm the opposite of you,
but in the same way,
I know that it has no value,
so I don't let it get
me too high or too low.
- [Man] Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Man] How do you define failure?
- Living your life based on other people.
- [Man] If you answered this to your son,
what would you tell him?
- To not listen to other people.
- [Man] Okay.
- Judgment, brother, it's
the poison of our society.
- [Man] Thank you.
- My friend, when people judge you,
that's an indication of them, not you.
- [Man] Alright.
You rock.
- Thank you, you rock, too.
(audience applauds)
- [Tom] Hey, this is my
catch man, cool, bro.
Uh, Gary, welcome back to Singapore.
I'm Tom.
I run a sales training
company here in Singapore.
So, for me, B2B is critical.
- Understood.
- [Tom] We loved LinkedIn.
- Yes.
- [Tom] So, how can we
really crush it on LinkedIn?
- How much content, don't bullshit me now,
cause I want you to win, how much content
are you guys putting out that doesn't
have the agenda of being
a top of the funnel
lead gen to people hiring you?
- [Tom] That doesn't have the agenda?
- Correct.
- [Tom] I know we can get a lot better.
We put up a lot of content, though.
- Got it?
- [Tom] We can fucking really get better.
- You're in the right hook,
right hook, right hook,
right hook business.
There's a reason I wrote
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
Go reread it, slowly.
- [Tom] Got it.
What do you think about LinkedIn ads?
Does it have the upside that Facebook has?
- It doesn't have a floor,
which is why I don't love it.
The reason I don't talk about it as much
is they've created an artificial price.
I still think it might be under priced,
but the good thing about
me through experience,
not the young me, is I
don't talk about things
until I fully, fully understand it fully.
My, here's what's blowing me away.
Organically, it's one of the
most interesting platforms.
Brother, you're not putting
out content for them,
you're putting it out for you.
- [Tom] Thank you, man.
- You're welcome.
- [Tom] Hey, Gary.
- How are you?
- [Tom] My name is Tom.
- Tom.
- [Tom] I just want to ask you,
there's a lot of digital platforms
that we can all leverage.
- Yes.
- [Tom] Right, is there way to build
an evergreen marketing funnel?
- Is there a what?
- [Tom] A way, a tactic, to build
an evergreen marketing funnel?
- Probably, but I wanna
understand, you know,
the evergreen marketing
funnel is called brand.
That's the actual evergreen model.
What I think you're asking
is something different,
so I want you to clarify it.
- [Tom] Cause every
content that you put out
on different platforms might require you
to change them constantly.
- Correct.
- [Tom] Is there
something that might never
go out of time, for example, say we can
market it for like one to two months?
Or even three months?
Doesn't work?
- No, because the consumer's attention,
the algorithms, the context, culture,
sometimes a word, overnight,
becomes offensive.
Almost nobody I've ever met in life
is actually consumer centric.
There's only two people that I've ever met
in the last 10 years, and one, excuse me,
one I watched, one I
met, that blew me away.
I said oh my god, they're
as consumer centric as me.
Jeff Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg.
Guess what, 10 years
later, they've got two
of the biggest fucking
companies in the world.
In 10 years, I'll be the most famous
fucking person on earth.
You know why?
When you are 100% focused on the customer,
and not what they can do for you,
do you know how many people here
worry about how many likes they have
verses worrying about
replying to the people
that actually gave them a like?
Selfish.
You guys are all fucking selfish.
I can smell it from a mile away.
I will tell you that you're selfish,
not because I wanna be
mean, because I want you
to be happy.
Brother, I know your
agenda's staying the same,
but you're basically telling
me fuck the customer,
and I wanna be lazy and
do one evergreen thing.
That's what you just said, Tom.
So, you better rethink
your fucking strategy.
- [Tom] Alright, got it,
thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome, brother.
- [Patricia] Hi, Gary, I'm Patricia.
- Hi, Patricia.
- [Patricia] I run a team of 20 staff,
and I know that you have
actually preached a lot
about entrepreneurship,
and at the same time,
you have a really big team as well, right.
So, how do you actually deal with people
on your team, especially those who
are overly ambitious, or people who
are inspired by your message, and they
wanna do something on their own?
- I want them to go do
something on their own.
- [Patricia] Okay.
- VaynerMedia can't be a jail.
If they're inspired, I
mean people come to me
all the time and go, you know, Gary,
when I first, I mean, a lot of people
start at VaynerMedia and never heard of me
which is a great accomplishment.
I want that to be the case.
They'll say you know, now I'm here a year,
and I've been listening to your stuff,
and wait a minute.
I think I wanna leave and do my own thing.
Every time, I go, let's go.
How can I help you?
- [Patricia] Fantastic, so you actually
go into a partnership, or do anything?
- That's rare.
It's happened.
I'm busy, and usually, like, if she wants
to start a paper company, or he wants
to start a cupcake company, like I'm busy,
but I'll introduce them to VC's.
I'll give them advice.
I'll try to help them.
The other thing is, I ask
them to be self-aware.
A lot of times, people don't
understand the transition
of, right now entrepreneurship is cool.
- [Patricia] Yes, it is.
- It's also very hard.
So, I ask them to figure out if they
actually are an entrepreneur.
- [Patricia] Okay, so you actually
bring them to your own
personal experience,
and see if they have the right mindset,
the beliefs, and--
- I ask questions.
I ask about their childhood.
I ask about them.
You know, if they work for me,
I've got a good read on them.
Usually, I can have some sort of read.
There's kids that I think that are,
and I think there are
kids that have no shot.
Kids, all ages.
I've pushed some people
to entrepreneurship,
and they think I'm trying
to get them to quit,
which is the weirdest conversations
I have with employees.
But, I know they'd be
happier being their own boss.
So, I'm empathetic.
- [Patricia] Okay, I'm excited
about you now being in Singapore.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Man] Last question, last question.
- [Man At Microphone] I'm a trainer,
and I just wanted to ask this question.
When you said about content,
is it purely content,
or, because right now,
I have my Facebook page.
So, I put up content about it there.
Or, the other thing is
I put up the content
plus call to action, which
is come to my training.
So, which one is, do you recommend?
- Both.
- [Man At Microphone] Both.
How frequent?
- A lot more of the things that are just
good content for them.
- [Man At Microphone] No call to action?
- Jab, jab, jab, right hook.
Give, give, give, ask.
- [Man At Microphone] So, the
other thing is the marketing.
You said marketing, marketing, marketing.
Put more, spend more money
on Facebook and Instagram.
So, how much percentage
are you talking about
from out of the profit, or
how much we talking about?
If I put a lot of money, I go broke.
- Well, don't go broke.
- [Man At Microphone]
That's what my question is.
- But, where's the money going?
- [Man At Microphone] What do you mean?
- Let me help you understand.
I run a $200 million company,
and don't make much money.
- [Man At Microphone] Is that
why you're still working?
- Because I love the process.
- [Man At Microphone] Okay, but don't you
love your life, and your
wife, and your family,
and your other things?
- Yes.
But, I also invest in my
business cause my business
is the thing that will let me love my wife
and my things forever.
- [Man At Microphone] But,
it has to be profitable.
- Of course.
- [Man At Microphone] So, my question is
how much percentage--
- As little, as little as possible.
- [Man At Microphone]
Little mean one percent,
two percent?
- That's not the right
way to think about it.
How much money do you need to take home
to pay for your life that
you're so happy about?
Let me ask you a question.
Do you need four sports jackets, or three?
Do you need 11 pairs of pants, or seven?
Do you need to go on
three vacations, or two?
My friend, every dollar you
put back into your business
gives you the potential
to have that business
be healthier long term.
Most people start businesses
to take the money out
to buy themselves things, which is why
they never build long term big businesses.
- [Man At Microphone] Okay, thank you.
- I just literally told you up here
that I was willing to give up my house
on the Upper East Side,
my home in the Hamptons,
and live in an apartment in Newark.
Life, and living your life, is based
on many different things.
There's people that make $150,000 a year,
and then when they make $200,000,
they're miserable, but
they were happy at 150.
That's real life.
So, you're defining your
life on an arbitrary number,
based on how much money
you made last year,
or how much you want to make this year.
That is not a mapping to the happiness.
Meanwhile, Facebook is
one of the best deals
of all time, happening right now.
So, you're not gonna invest as much
as properly needed because
you wanna buy stuff.
By the way, Mazel Tov, enjoy.
You do you, but that's the debate.
- [Man At Microphone] Yeah,
because a lot of people
say come out from the comfort zone,
but I just fucking love the comfort zone
because this is life.
- Mazel Tov.
Just, don't complain when your business
doesn't grow that much
over the next decade.
You're not feeding your business.
You're feeding yourself.
Good, but you better fucking shut up
about why am I not growing.
You know why you're not growing.
You're not feeding it.
So, to answer your
question, why do I do it,
cause I love the process
more than the other stuff.
You love the other stuff
more than the process.
That's okay.
I don't think I'm right.
That's just who we are.
So, I'll probably build
billion dollar companies,
and you won't.
It doesn't mean I'm right.
You might have more
vacations, and eat more food,
and go to more matches,
and spend more time
with people, that's great.
Life is about choices,
but you can't have both.
I think when there's a
moment in time that's special
like this, it's probably a good idea
to take advantage of it.
You can go back to being comfortable
three years later, and oh by the way,
that comfortable tends to be far better
than it was three years earlier.
- [Man At Microphone]
So, just like you said,
about Facebook, the one
that you go through,
the Google ads and all
those things, right,
so it's like, are you
saying that you know,
a few people, a few months
you're saying Facebook
become more expensive this year?
- It did.
- [Man At Microphone] Are you saying
that it's gonna be fucking
more expensive in coming years?
- Yes.
- [Man At Microphone] Thank you.
- And, by the way, it's
still a ridiculous deal.
- [Man At Microphone] Cheap.
- Because when you buy
something for two dollars,
then it's six dollars,
you think it's expensive,
but if you realize it's
actually worth $75.
- [Man At Microphone] Thank you.
- [Man] Thank you, everybody
give Gary a big hand.
Thank you so much.
Gary, we really appreciate it.
- [Gary] Thank you, thank you, guys.
(upbeat music)